[Music]
in false wealth news Oh liar submitted
by employees only I feel like there's a
lot of fakers on istagram this pretend
billionaires through insane parties for
celebs and then vanished without the
great gatsby like the bill came in I've
never seen them when we were at them
yeah I thought he was a fake no whoa
well it was more so like you know all of
this money can be from light mention him
to okay that's me in this story Oh
all this wolf came from like Prohibition
like liquor selling like alcohol type
stuff you know what I mean so it was all
more like quite shady stuff but yeah the
whole thing was he did it for love right
yeah for that girl
what a loser no no this story this story
okay honey we're talking about cats
because Leo DiCaprio was in one of these
photos all right so this dude he's
Malaysian born
his name is Joe low Joe how low can you
Joe man so he did come from or he does
come from a wealthy family but like his
dad was known as like a sleazy kind of
like he got there got their money like
sleazy scammy kind of way you slimy
slimy yeah and that's pretty much how he
ended up being because this dude he
would growing up he would pretend to
have money like more money than he had
cuz you have money right now is it all
right so yeah this guy here so he would
throw these crazy extravagant parties
get out of the room get out get out of
this video right now I'm like the
opposite I want people to think I got
nothing oh yeah you want to be a target
for a [ __ ] robbery burglary into like
a Jaguar like a ram that's not rich
that's not really that's not rich
Rolexes
but that's like right this sounds like
you very rich wealthy yeah there's a
difference between liking those things
and buying it to impress people -
there's like dudes that take a bath tub
and [ __ ] put hundreds of dollars like
this and then they [ __ ] lay in it and
then they're just flossing and they're
like in-your-face haters right there's
that time pretty funny by the way I
would do that if you're constantly doing
it you attract a certain type of people
yeah free [ __ ] if it's yeah it's a real
friend - you attract a certain type of
people within your circle of friends
it's not a front dog then that just
means you're about it yeah like
Mayweather like we all know he has money
but he also is like flossing it all the
time - oh I don't know it just attracts
a certain kind of attention that I do
not want rich people problems from
scammers - real rich people got rich
people problems that's just messed up
any of those problems like what rich
family is like like grandchildren will
like ransom themselves in order to grab
money from like yeah that's what I'm
talking about
patio needs a [ __ ] private army to
protect his family that's just why ain't
nobody gonna kidnap me for a [ __ ]
Rolex since that's the stupidest [ __ ]
you should kidnap me for I'll [ __ ]
[ __ ] on myself and rub it all over them
oh dang all over the realest I'm like
the worst person to kidnap I'll start
[ __ ] chewing through the Rope like a
rat and I'll [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] chew
through them I'll make them regret
kidnapping me ever I'll cook their
animals and start eating go kidnap Joe
ok can we move on thank you so this Joe
love si be creative he's gonna go to the
[ __ ] where's your [ __ ] kitchen where
is your kitchen where's your cat
as a mouth guard talking [ __ ] dog I'll
go [ __ ] the warrants president kid now
you wait up on your pets man I'll go say
let me use your [ __ ] bathroom and
I'll get the toilet roll and if I can
turn this [ __ ] right around man
I'll get the towels and I'll start
rearranging that [ __ ] they're
gonna be all kinds of OCD [ __ ] up
they're gonna go in there and [ __ ]
like drawers and see that the underwear
drawer is [ __ ] been replace with the
sock drawer
I'll [ __ ] change the hot dog with the
cult and then they're always gonna be
taking [ __ ] cold showers thinking
that the waters broken yeah and then
three seconds later they [ __ ] figure
it out and they're like okay so I gotta
turn the cold and all you gotta do is
turn the [ __ ] hot water heater off
hold showers but you know how long would
they take until they realize that the
knobs are switched
three seconds everything like that this
guy's also taking a shower laughter he
kidnapped og like they let Joe walk
around the house use everything while I
go take his challenge we haven't heard
anything about this real guy who might
actually be kidnapped
Joell oh okay so dolo here he's been
criminally indicted thank you in
Malaysia and so they're saying that he
siphoned off or he helped siphon off
billions of dollars from this Malaysian
investment fun state-owned Malaysian
investment fund and he did it through
fraudulent deals and complex money
laundering Wow best well-known for
having these like super tight
connections with celebrities at one
point apparently he he offered to fund
the wolf of Wall Street the movie yeah
the movie because it was like this one
moment where the studio was gonna back
out
he's like reverse Robin Hood and yeah
he's like reverse Robin Hood's he's
gotta steal from people's tax money and
then give it to celebrities that's true
huh yeah yeah that's exactly what I and
yeah so there's just like a lot of
photos maybe the Ludacris Luda you know
you look like this is normal as Asian
bird but what if he's like hella hood
and [ __ ] cuz he loves like rapping he
likes gangster movies and [ __ ] he
doesn't look like he's gonna be hella
hood this photo is different
yeh he grew up seeing his dad always
throwing these lavish parties with
celebrities and stuff so like that's
kind of like where he kind of got it
from so now if he ran to China because
he has some really tight connections in
China it seems like China can be kind of
protecting him too because he had like a
lot of business deals with people like
very powerful people in China and he
moved some money over there or something
probably so as in right now they're
thinking he's somewhere in either Hong
Kong Macau or Shenzhen I wonder if he's
mixed legit with actually shitty
business like I wonder if he did both I
don't know but basically he's been using
shady money to kind of fund his parties
and all that and to like you try to look
legit yeah he tried legit legit he try
to look like he had way more money than
he actually did cuz he didn't have as
much money as he wanted like he did I
think a lot of people do that it's just
not as rich a lot of people do that
because they think like oh if they think
that I'm like them they'll give me
business deals they will do things with
me and then I will become rich yeah yeah
there might be like a eight figure
person that pretends to be a billionaire
mm-hmm I mean that's gonna be really
hard to pretend but that's what he was
he's pretending to be a billionaire oh
[ __ ] that's way hard to pull off
compared to just like a ten millionaire
or whatever you yeah cuz like ten
millionaire is like oh I'll I'll ride
share a private jet with other
millionaires right and then a hundred
million air is like oh I got my own
private jet with my own pilot but then a
billionaire has their own air airline
okay Richard likelike Branson or what
they have their own airline or whatever
yes Amen jello when she was a teenager
cuz he went to school and like this
really prestigious school in London and
that when they some of his friends went
to go visit him in Malaysia that he had
one of his richer friends his family's
yacht like he borrowed it to throw a
party and he changed all the family
photos from his friends family to his
family to pretend like that was his
yacht oh my mom you look at them maybe
that's the only way you can make friends
and I'm saying you know what I mean like
you always like overexert yourself in
other areas to overcompensate for your
insecurities right and you know what's
sad is that he grew up watching his dad
do this and he idolized him yeah you
know you kind of learn your [ __ ] from
your parents or you don't want to be
less than what your father wanted you to
be you know you better be a good shady
[ __ ] just like your daddy this
yeah this is one of those inception
moments where you got to ask first like
how's this guy's relationship with his
father yeah he also has two older
siblings a brother and a sister and yeah
like the father had very high
aspirations raised it is you're not
gonna just scam ten people like daddy
you gonna skim a thousand people but
imagine growing up in your dad right
it's a little bit slimy he's like you
gotta you gotta fake the funk you got to
make people believe that you're more
than you're worth if you ever want to be
where I think that's right yeah cuz I
had classmates well they're my friends
and their dad was like in and out of
prison and they're like they glamorize
that gang life yeah rappers kind of do
that anyway right like they talk about
their money and their girls and their
cars all and then they're their own will
or something like they don't have it so
yes or they got like a two hundred
thousand advance on an album and they
blew it all or some [ __ ] yeah that's the
same [ __ ] to me it's like faking the
[ __ ] is like I think it's it when you
know like when you actually know rich
people or whatever it's easy to tell
you're the richest the wealthiest people
in the world they definitely don't
flaunt anything but I feel like a lot of
these people even if they could tell
they don't don't [ __ ] care because if
you're celebrity and you yourself is
rich you don't care mm-hmm it's almost
like okay cool you on my level all right
whatever let's go let's go party All
Right see ya I'm off to the next party
[Music]